oops
we'll always come at a cost
hey everybody its charlie huge news Sony
dropped a promo for the venom sequel
this past weekend and almost nobody
noticed it because of the avalanche of
other people dropping trailers and
footage so we got to break this down
obviously spoiler warning if you have
not seen venom yet because we'll be
talking about the post-credits scene and
some of the clearer things that they set
up pretty much what you'd expect there's
also a new round of that spider-man ps4
game giveaway going on this week all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a venom related
comment on the video be sure to stick
around to the end of the video because
there is a hot off the presses Marvel
scoop that I'll add to the end of this
after I talk about all this venom
carnage stuff so this past weekend the
post-credits scene confirmed what
everybody believed going into the movie
if you can't directly do a spider-man in
a venom movie the next best option is to
do carnage so going into the movie a lot
of us just expected that they would
somehow T up some sequel and show
carnage in some way and sure enough
that's what they did with the
post-credits see I've already done a
video about the two post-credit scenes
make sure you stay through the end
credits too for the spider verse Tia
wallets for the animated movie there is
a lot of interesting discussion
happening around the way Sony T's up
that what effectively is an ad for their
movie coming out in December please buy
tickets for our movie with spider-man
related stuff happening the special
promo that Sony dropped this past
weekend is basically the full backstory
of carnage that they've already
established within the world of this
venom verse whatever you want to call
the world of venom I used to refer to it
as Sony spider verse but Tom Hardy more
recently in interviews has been calling
it the venom verse which i think is
probably more accurate because even
though there are other spider-man's
spin-off characters that will appear in
this Sony spider-verse eventually we
don't know exactly when we're gonna get
that Tom Holland crossover so what's
happened here is is they basically just
done a promo for Eddie's interview with
Cletus Kasady that you get in that post
credit scene so it's like the next
moment after this as Eddie begins to
interview him and learn about his life
there are a lot of Easter eggs in here
there
mostly accurate to his comic book back
story in the comics albeit this is
happening in San Francisco and not in
New York City area which is where Eddie
wound up in prison in a cell with Cletus
Kasady which led to the birth of comic
book carnage so obviously the venom
verse version of this is gonna be a
little bit different some of this story
is just vicious - so Cletus Kasady
pushed his grandmother down a flight of
stairs killing her later going on a huge
massacre in New York City before
slaughtering 11 people in Rikers maximum
security penitentiary there's actually a
direct reference to the comic book
origin where he gets the symbiote then
busts right out the Venom symbiote had
come to rescue Eddie Brock he
immediately burst right through the wall
didn't really take too many guards out
but when Cassidy got the carnage
symbiote he immediately turned around
and just took out a whole bunch of
guards there was actually a reference to
Eddie Brock's time at the Daily Globe
which is a reference to a spider-man
comic book story so there were some
references to the spider-man character
in the venom movie I'll do an Easter Egg
video with everything in a couple days
the interview with Cletus Kasady goes on
though it gets even worse
Brock learned that Cassidy had an
oedipal complex and once dug up his
mother's grave the brooklyn-born mass
murderer is described by Eddie is a
homicidal maniac with an insane mind and
a lust for destruction if you're not a
big comic book reader just think of it
as venom having his own version of the
Joker someone that wants to watch the
world burn as a child and orphaned
Cassidy grew up in st. Estes home for
boys that's also right out of the comics
which was later set aflame Eddie
correctly suspects that it was Cletus
Kasady like it was in the comics all for
the purported purpose of killing the
disciplinarian administrator the Cassidy
did not like the notes' go on Cassidy
tortured and killed his mother's dog
with a drill once pushed a girl in front
of a bus instantly killing her when she
rejected his advances some of the notes
detail Cassidy's ethos according to
Brock like he's trying to parse what it
all means for him if he's just doing all
this because he likes to do it or for
some grand design behind it they kind of
allude to it during the post-credits
scene the way he frames Cassidy's mind
actually does sound like a couple of
things that they talked about during the
course of the venom movie when the
symbiote comes to Eddie Brock and tries
to explain that they can do whatever
they
so he says that Cassidy seeks the
ultimate freedom truly doing whatever
you want so imagine the Venom symbiote
is tempered by Eddie's desire to only
hurt bad people in sort of agrees to
that so you imagined someone like
Cassidy gets a symbiote the symbiote
will just feed off of what he wants to
do we can truly do whatever we want let
me know though if you were at New York
comic-con
and you spotted this because this isn't
something that they posted online this
is something that people found walking
around on the comic-con floor but it
lets you know that they already thought
out his backstory and how he's going to
fit into the universe before they hired
Woody Harrelson to play the character in
that post-credit scene whatever you
thought of the way they treated
spider-man comic book cannon in the
venom original origin story during the
movie I think the sequel promo just lets
us know that they intend to be as
authentic as possible to the comic book
origin story of carnage obviously
they're in San Francisco now not in New
York City so there'll be a couple minor
changes but just remember I know we're
all thinking that maximum carnage might
be the title of the sequel and serve as
the basis for the story there were
actually a number of carnage vs. venom
fights in spider-man fights that
happened before they did the maximum
carnage comic book art because there is
a version of that story that Sony could
do that would be sort of their version
of infinity war that they build up
towards where it just goes really crazy
or they could do one of their earlier
encounters and just call it maximum
carnage I think they're just gonna go
for maximum appeal so gauge your
expectations accordingly but let me know
like what do you actually want them to
do with carnage inside the venom verse
of Sony movies because we have the
Morbius movie with Jared Leto that's
probably gonna get made we also have the
Kraven the hunter movie which is also
pretty likely to get made because he's
such a big character they haven't said
much about how they're gonna use that
character but as for now it seems like
they can't use Tom Holland at least yet
so that would probably mean that Kraven
the hunter would be hunting venom
instead of hunting spider-man makes
pretty easy sense I don't know if I
would want to see a Kraven the hunter
movie if you don't have any of the
spider related characters in it but let
me know in the comments they have a
couple really big characters besides Tom
Hollands spider-man how do you want them
to all use these in crossover movies or
do you just want them to be more
standalone what happened this past
weekend is it blue
pass box office expectations buy a lot
which I think assures that a sequel
regardless of what happens in subsequent
weeks even if the box office dropped
sharply so Sony hasn't made any official
announcement or dated when they're gonna
do that venom carnage movie but just
expect that within the next two years
they've signed Tom Hardy for a trilogy
my expectation is is that they'll shoot
for the Tom Holland crossover if they
think they can actually pull that off
for that third film just because we have
the Spider Man far from home movie
coming out next year there will
inevitably be a third film that Sony
will do with Marvel meaning the Tom
Holland will probably be tied up with
MCU goings on for the next several years
beyond that I think it's a little hard
to predict the big Marvel scoop while I
was finishing this video is is the James
Gunn was announced to direct and right
Suicide Squad - at DC so first Bendis
now James Gunn what'll happen is is if
you guys really want I'll do a separate
video about that the Disney CEO made
some very specific statements about what
his stance was on James Gunn in general
making this Marvel to DC jump inevitable
but what's gonna happen is is I'll do my
venom Easter eggs video in the next
couple of days the flash episode one is
back tonight so we'll do a video for
that next just leave all your Marvel
video requests in the comments below and
I'll leave that spider-man game giveaway
open in all my Marvel videos this week
I'll remind people when I post new
spider-man click here for the venom post
credits and click here for that new Tom
Holland Avengers 4 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you